urubus pessoal bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e hoje bom ensinar como fazer uma
pistola do papel que lhes para um lado
que quando vocês pressionam no gatilho e
melhor para é que você estava oxidado
duas folhas de papel para fazer este
projeto
então bora lá primeiro ensaio do grupo
folha ao maio e usar aqui uma folha a4 a
emissora mas vocês podem usar outras
folhas quaisquer sankay dobra em quase
para a linha dos filhos deixa o pequeno
de 300 linhas vincadas lá no banho e
extremidade da folha veja mas não menos
10,3 cento e entre os dois meses
nesta parte a podem brincar para a linha
do centro que tem que fazer o mesmo por
outro lado não esquecendo de deixar
aquela e na distância atravessa é muito
importante
tem que fazer agora uma dobra ao maio
uma questão de orientação quem vocês vão
ver a seguir podem fazer também logo no
início você quiser
foi mais fácil pra vocês fazer duas
coisas destas
e vejam e uma guia linha do douro no
centro melhor
encostei que o mesmo lá na minha e do
brasil desta maneira assim
paralelo à ht de que é possível fazer
mesmo outro lado mas por outro lado eu
vim aqui e turvar parlamento através
agora vão ter que alterar a gu pm o
dólar cai
vejam fazer de modo e com um triângulo
com todos os lados é iguais ou seja um
triângulo equilátero gasolina em maio e
21 outra vez ali nas partes porque
entraram que tinha fé
jogando desta maneira para dentro cair
já que aquelas parte como para dentro
ajustem melhor
e punham um cano
mas atenção só vejam que aquela abertura
vai ficar para baixo é importante ficou
pactuada por cima fez ou colocadas de
maneira bastante simples e vejam que
encaixam na perfeição uma vez que vocês
fizeram aquela coisa por nuno lado da
linha e no outro é então fica tudo certo
já está se vocês quiserem podem parar
por aqui e ficou com uma arma do origin
ge que vocês querem por aqui lá para te
fará então não tem que fazer um pequeno
corte desta maneira
acho que mais vocês podem fazer um crime
maior e mais provável é que vão ter que
cortar usando um x-ato usuário que não
precisará de um homem de frente para
aquelas operações mas bastante barato
aqui em inglaterra e comprar uma caixa
que trazia três coisinhas desta zin
várias lâminas e questão do são paulo
mas precisa também da fazenda
se vocês forem crianças peçam já rodou
também vejam que vão fazer outro corta
lá no department educandário macáe e tem
que ficar assim cruzar ou seja se você
imaginar em uma linha que vai do carro
lado ao outro ea linha 8 corta-se uma
prova e faz uma cruz 90 graus na sessão
isso porque para cuidar ficar preso
tivesse inclinado para a frente não vai
não vai era ter o elástico ou seja vai
escapar e para fortalecer a arma só
porque os clips ou então podem usar fita
se vocês quiserem
é mais fácil e mais rápida
mas há um pequeno corpo ali na frente
para você se encaixar nesse lastex
então já está feito agora só falta mesmo
que achar os elásticos utilizar aquele
lacen que agora estão muito na moda para
fazer pulseiras e que acreditem que vão
muito longe com muita força é porque
porquê e eu chicão quase ao máximo eu
seja a atenção que eles têm é muito
grande
não vale a pena vocês por um elástico
muito grandes no futebol se dedicado ao
máximo a cair é franca já está é só
tocar ali no gatilho e o elástico sair
do esperado e precisam dessa arma é
muito boa mesmo e pronto
ao chegarmos ao fim eu espero nenhum
estado e se vocês gostaram mesmo este
vosso rainha o vosso favorito e se
inscreva no canal que estuda ajudou
bastante divulgação e evolução do meu
trabalho e claro que tiverem mais
sugestões de projetos
deixe nos comentários que agradeço mesmo
porque isso me inspira bastante e tem
feito quase tudo que você espera é e só
um grande abraço e até a próxima disse
ao i